not gonna lie to you guys I knew nothing
about this movie till a couple days ago
no salamis movie coming out this weekend
alright what's it about it's totally
it's about dr. Martin Luther King
jr. - pretty important biographical
picture that I didn't know about 48
hours Pryor's let's do this
[Music]
Selma so Selma is a movie about dr.
Martin Luther King jr. it's not about
his entire life I love how biographical
pictures are kind of doing this now they
know that people don't necessarily want
to see from birth to death that just
gets kind of long-winded at times this
is about a specific point in his life in
his civil rights movement that was
happening calling it his civil rights
movements kind of downplaying it's the
civil rights movement and in that the
town they're in it's crooked as
tensions are high and here we are
the dude who plays dr. Martin Luther
King jr. in this movie this David Oh
yellow I was like I don't know anything
about this guy well I don't I know
anything about this guy where did he
come from this a good thing about these
gems that kind of fly under the radar
stay might just showcase someone who
that's absurdly great acting talent oh
my god this was like watching dr. Martin
Luther King jr. like right in front of
you he's actually the doctor and rise to
the Planet of the Apes I didn't know
that I am DB did enough the movie was
over I was like I don't know what you're
in you tell me what your red got it was
really cool he's British oh my god he
hid that accent well and gained an
entirely new one but I love how this
movie peels away the legend because at
this point dr. Martin Luther King jr.
hear about it he's dr. Martin Luther
King jr. he had all the answers he had
the movement he never strayed from the
course he was like I know we're going to
succeed March March March this is kind
of how he's taught to everybody but it's
not like that behind that there's a guy
who at a point and this whole thing was
like I don't know if we're gonna win I
love seeing mamas like that it's like
Saving Private Ryan when Tom Hanks gets
behind the rock where no one can see him
and he breaks down you're like oh yeah
you gotta like stay the course as the
leader but in the end you're a guy
you're a human you're a mortal man it's
important for movies to show that when
the legends are too big normal people
are like oh I can't do something like
that because he's him and I'm just me
but in the end II he's just him he's
just like you it's important for movies
to show that to us a good job on this
movie some of the in this movie is
just hard to watch you watch you're like
that happened it's just a really dark
time it's one of those things well yeah
there's laws and stuff in place but when
you're in a town where the cards are
just completely stacked against you and
anyone who has your skin color yeah it
gets really bad and I love the fight you
know me I love me my politics in my
movies I love the fact that it showed a
political chess game happening in the
movie among
movement LBJ was president at the time
and his show that he had his reason for
being like yeah dr. Martin Luther King
jr. why don't you go ahead and lead the
movement and Martin Luther King jr. had
his things that he had to do you know
there were politics involved knows like
that's it's not just kind of like
alright everyone let's March and it'll
get it done there were a lot of cogs in
play and it just kind of gets lost
through translation among the decades so
we're a couple of moments to say
something tragic happens and it goes to
this slow-mo shot it's a really long
slow-mo shot really long and a long shot
can be effective but it when it's too
long you're like alright still a slow-mo
shot then we're still here we're still
here it gives you time during the
slow-mo shot to think about the effect
of what the shot would have been if it
wasn't a slo-mo shot it actually would
have been a little more real and
possibly a little more effective if it
felt a little more real thus it
shouldn't have been a slo-mo shot at
least not that long in the end Selma
surprised me because like I said last
week I didn't know about this movie the
acting was great the one who plays dr.
Martin Luther King jr. in this movie
David Oh yellow keep your eye out for
that guy oh my god he's he's gonna get
more work I just don't call on it now
because I like calling the obvious it's
kind of like when that light turns green
cars are gonna go it's that obvious to
me to say this dudes gonna get a lot
more working you're gonna see him a lot
more the well-acted movie a
well-directed movie an effective movie
Selma is definitely worth buying on
blu-ray great movie go say if you see
taking three over this you get slapped
by life so what happens don't give takin
your money don't let take and take you
all right so Selma have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you wanna see more click right here
to see more
[Music]